what sparked the break you know I fell
in love with boxing and I fell out of
love with Santa all right you and give
have had a war of words on Twitter on
Instagram for a while now
yeah is it you want to call them
something different no I just people
have been calling him Jim people have
been calling him good so I don't know I
asked him before our interview and I was
like Gibby he's like yeah give ok ok you
don't even know how to say his name no I
I don't know I mean I still don't know I
think everyone's still find out my fans
you know they're like starting to get
excited about this fight but I no one
really knows who he is
so I'm not trying to be by like yeah
well then why is now the time to fight
him why even do this yeah so I did a
poll on Twitter and I put out a bunch of
opponents on the poll I was like dear
internet who should I fight and all the
people on the poll you know tweeted out
to the fan base and his fan base
actually got the most amount of votes so
I was like all right he won the poll I'm
gonna fight him that's what's the most
fair that's what makes the most sense
and for me this is a stepping he's a
stepping stone to avenge my brother's
lost against ksi so I beat ksi his
brother Gabe slash jib is ksi his best
friend and I'm gonna beat him and then
go after ksi and avenge my brother's
lost because we all know that Logan
should have won that fight and
unfortunately got two points taken away
and that's that was the decision but to
me there's a doormat stepping-stone to
fight ksi do you feel like there's more
pressure on you because of what happened
with your brother and ksi no I mean I
think it motivates me it motivates me to
work harder yeah it might have been
motivates me to you know put that extra
work in and also realize that like
anything could happen and that's why
that's why you have to be prepared for
anything you have to have high boxing IQ
know what's going on in the ring not hit
people when they're on the on the mat
and and just be smarter
how have you been training for this walk
me kind of through that process yes we
have a rigorous training camp up in Big
Bear California so we're high in the
altitude the oxygen is thin there so
naturally everything is twice as hard so
if you do six rounds in Big Bear it's
like doing 12
down the mountain and I'm training with
Sugar Shane Mosley boxing legend he's
teaching me how to be a champion how to
train like a champion eat like a
champion think like a champion and he's
been he's been a blessing in disguise
you know instilled so much confidence in
me and just turned me into a different
breed of fighter but I'm I'm more
prepared for anything than ever and it
just it's just exciting if you win how
will you celebrate when I win I'm gonna
win so we're gonna be in Miami
yo Miami is one of my favorite cities in
the world after party at 11 so it's
going down shout out mark Roberts shout
out Dave Grubman it's going down you
know we're about to take over Miami
afterwards and it's Super Bowl weekend
so you know it's going down but Gibb if
you're watching this bro if you behave
well throughout this entire process I'll
let you come to my after-party at 11
okay like if you want to come I'll let
you in but you have to behave you got to
be nice buddy you got to be nice it's
funny because I asked is there like hate
between you guys like what is this and
he doesn't hate you
how do you feel towards him yeah there's
no there's no animosity I again I didn't
even know who he was months ago and this
is his this is the biggest moment of his
career you know he's using my name to
grow his career that's the bottom line
that's that's fast and there's no way
around that and this is his 15 seconds
of fame he's seven and a half seconds in
you know he's gonna suck all all that he
can out of this and it's and it's great
for him you know I'm I'm proud of him if
I were in his shoes you know I'd be just
as excited as he is he's in the
interviews like the so you know I get it
but I don't hate the kid you know I
think I think he's a little cringe but
other than that I'm just gonna knock him
out move on to ksi you have been going
through a lot in your personal life
though because you and Tana just
announced the break it's not really a
break up it's a break what sparked the
break you know I fell in love with
boxing and I fell out of love with Tana
and not even in love anymore
I mean I always loved her I always loved
her you know I think we're just better
off as friends when
when we kind of made that decision it
was like a weight lifted off of both of
our shoulders and it kind of reminded us
like how the relationship started which
was friends and you know she's an
amazing girl it just wasn't the right
right time for us and we both have
things to focus on and you know we're
working on certain things together as
well so it's it's great that we're still
able to you know have a great amazing
relationship is there a chance you guys
get back together I don't know what the
future holds come on come on we'll see I
really don't know if you asked me like
three years ago would I be standing here
right now doing a interview about boxing
and knocking kids out I'd be like
absolutely not on my Disney Channel and
I'm a vlogger so like I I don't know
what the future holds but you know you
never know when you guys said break were
there rules in place like you can't see
other people you can see other people
we're gonna reevaluate in a certain
amount of time
there's the there weren't rules you know
I think it was kind of just open
communication is kind of what we just
talked about but yeah I feel like she'll
be dating people and obviously I'm
focused on this but who knows what will
happen after after my fight if I have
free time and you know it's Hollywood
and and anything can happen so I mean
you're letting her keep your Lambo
hahaha that was a joke yeah no no no no
joke no yeah you get the dog you're
keeping the Lambo
yeah for sure no wait we didn't we're
not like taking each other's belongings
and because I was gonna ask you how do
you decide who gets what but that's not
really a thing that's happening will
there be a divorce party I feel like
that would be so much yes yes we're
throwing a rager for the divorce and
only single people are allowed if you
guys wanna if it any brands out there
want to sponsor email brands at team ten
official com
that's hilarious when will this when
will this happen probably sometime after
the fight but yeah it's going down
I love that um and before I let you go
what I really loved about when your
brother fought he had quite the
entourage behind him during his walk out
we saw Justin Bieber there who do you
have lined up um I'm kind of dedicating
this fight to America you know there's
like this UK versus America beef and I
think people get sometimes forget about
this that and for me this fights about
America and showing American pride and
so I'm gonna be walking out with some
members of our military and kind of
dedicating the fight to America so
amazing I love that yeah did your
brother get NASCAR beer did your brother
give you any advice before this he
grabbed me by the neck and said you have
to win you know for our family name and
our family legacy and train your often
make this your mission and don't think
about anything else and and really lock
in and and and go go get them you know
and don't don't overlook it because you
know anything can happen and you know
just like what happened in Logans right
so you know take it seriously was is a
piece of advice and just work hard not
to bring the mood down but if you do
lose if what what happens next question
it's not a question yeah do you have a
message for your opponent give you know
suck all of this suck all suck
everything out of this that you can and
honestly
train train hard buddy cuz rumor is that
you're not training hard rumor is that
you're kind of going and lackadaisical
so train hard and bring everything you
can into that ring and let's put on a
show and then before I let you go it's
been reported today that your guys's
friend Justin Bieber has Lyme disease
how is yeah how is he doing do you know
how he's doing um you know I haven't
spoken to him about that I haven't seen
the reports but man that's that's a lot
to do with I'm sorry to hear that
that's my cousin has Lyme disease and I
know how
like hard and difficult that can be and
how serious it can be so that's
heartbreaking news damn then that sucks
and then sorry Justin Rob supporting you
and really fast will Tana be in Miami to
watch the fight
yeah Tana will be there let's go you
guys are friends no matter what
yeah love Janna forever
[Music]